>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington,DC.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Hello,
this is Juan Felipe Herrera,
US Poet Laureate and I'm here
at the Special Collections
and Rare Books Division
with Mark Manivong.
And we have been looking at
these beautiful materials
that Mark is going to
begin to tell us about.
What do we have here, Mark?
>> Mark Manivong: Well first
I pulled some materials
from our Sylvester &
Orphanos collection.
Sylvester & Orphanos is a small
publisher in Los Angeles, CA.
They did about 25 fine editions
of works by popular authors,
and culminating with their
Tsarouchis volume which is a tribute
to the Greek artist Tsarouchis.
It includes about 36
serigraphs and several tributes
from other authors and painters.
>> Herrera: You know, we were
talking about that collection,
and it's a pretty big collection
in addition to the prints
and art...tell us a little bit about
the art of Tsarouchis actually.
>> Manivong: Okay.
Well, he's a modern Greek painter.
He was most active from about
1930 through about 2000.
He does a lot of very realistic,
very raw paintings,
most of which are men.
A lot of his paintings
are homo-erotic.
The women that he paints
are typically very strong,
very much like a Frida Kahlo figure.
>> Herrera: That's right.
We notice that.
And what is the medium?
It's a very...it looks like a
watercolor...looks like acrylic.
>> Manivong: Acrylic.
>> Herrera: Acrylic.
>> Manivong: Typically.
He did do some drawings, some
charcoal and pen and ink I believe.
And he was also active in the
theatre and he did set designs.
>> Herrera: Ohhh...I
didn't know that part.
Oh, that's amazing.
And...what about the tributes.
This is also very interesting.
>> Manivong: Yes.
The tributes are from authors and
other painters, some hoteliers
and other major figures--
authors such as Odysseus Elytis,
who was the Poet Laureate of
Poetry, pardon me, in 1976.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Manivong: Yes, and Reynolds
Price, a major American author.
James Merrill, another major
American author and poet.
>> Herrera: And this is
done on letter press?
>> Manivong: Yes it is.
>> Herrera: That's a
lot of good work there.
>> Manivong: And the
tributes were in both English
and then you could turn it
over and they're in Greek.
>> Herrera: That's right.
That's right.
I'm really moved by this.
I'm really inspired by
the work of this artist.
And I was looking at the faces.
They kind of remind me of a litle
bit, of course it's very different,
of Matisse's faces and
the dark outline pencil.
>> Manivong: Yes.
>> Herrera: That's beautiful.
>> Manivong: Yes
>> Herrera: And the other work
that you showed me was....
>> Manivong: Well, the collection,
these are the...a selection
of the 25 editions
that they published.
And then, as part
of that acquisition we
also received their archive
for all 25 editions of their books.
So I pulled out one archive.
Each archive is divided
into...by publication.
And then this one is for
John Cheevers' Expelled,
a miniature book.
And included in the
archive are letters
from the publishers requesting
permission to publish a work,
any kind of responses the received
from writers or their agents,
and here we have a
selection of letters
from the artist they contracted
with to do with the book.
And this particular
artist, Warren Chappell,
in all of his publications he
would include a little drawing
on his letterhead.
>> Herrera: That's what I really
liked about these letters.
You wouldn't see this
kind of material at all
if we hadn't collected
it or acquired it.
And it's so beautiful because
the handwriting of the artist,
and it's a letter, and then the
artist decides to draw something
on that letter and just kind
of gobble up the whole page.
I like that.
>> Manivong: And some of them
are quite intricate drawings.
>> Herrera: That's true.
>> Manivong: Yes.
>> Herrrera: We have...what
is this like a...
>> Manivong: A gargoyle.
>> Herrera: Like a
gargoyle and we have a...
[ Laughter ]
>> Herrera: Who's this guy?
>> Manivong: I have no idea!
>> Herrera: He looks
kind of stately there.
And then we have like a clown
balancing a feather-- and on and on.
And different colors and
different inks and everything.
I love this.
It's like we could do letters,
on kind of a stationary,
responding to a publisher and then
we could add our drawings in there.
That's beautiful.
So I think that's great.
>> Manivong: And part of the...the
other part of the archive,
we also have author-corrected
proof pages so you could track back
and see if there are any
changes text over the years,
over multiple publications and
where that change may have occurred.
We have samples of
bindings, gatherings,
the individual gatherings
from the publication.
>> Herrera: And the gatherings are
before the book is actually bound
and produced.
They're like, let's see what
it looks like...and these are
the gatherings.
So we have gatherings for
even a small size like that.
>> Manivong: Okay.
The next collection I'd like
to show you is our Poet's
Laureate collection.
This collection is made up of all
the works of the Poets Laureate.
We collect every title,
every edition.
And that frequently includes
small press works, broadsides,
anything that the Poets
have produced.
>> Herrera: That's amazing.
I'm looking at the, this
one by Maxine Kumin.
When was that done?
>> Manivong: Yeah, I
don't know exactly.
I can check.
>> Herrera: A while ago.
That's for sure.
>> Manivong: But typically,
these are signed
by the poets when they're here.
This is from 1992.
>> Herrera: 1992.
That's a very nice looking book.
>> Manivong: But anything that
she's produced we will add it
to our collection.
>> Herrera: Right.
And then the broadsides.
>> Manivong: Broadsides are amazing.
These are typically single poems
and they are combined with artwork,
most often a woodblock print.
Sometimes there's a drawing or a
small painting that goes on them.
They are usually done in limited
edition, so maybe about a hundred
to a hundred and fifty copies.
>> Herrera: That's what I
noticed that there are not many,
there are not like 200 or
300, there's around a hundred.
>> Manivong: Right.
>> Herrera: Yeah like a hundred.
There's not like a thousand.
>> Manivong: Right.
>> Herrera: It's a short edition.
And then they're also
signed, and numbered
and signed mostly in pencil.
>> Manivong: Right.
>> Herrera: That's interesting.
Not all of the time,
but most of the time.
>> Manivong: And they're
usually done by fine presses.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Manivong: And we even
have your works right here,
the most recent Poet Laureate.
>> Herrera: I just noticed.
Good going.
>> Manivong: Thank you.
>> Herrera: And this is
a bigger piece over here.
>> Manivong: Right.
That's a fine press book by
a small press in Richmond,
VA and it's Charles
Wright's Yard Journal.
And this has what I believe,
I think these are serigraphs
combined with his poetry.
>> Herrera: Very nice.
Kind of a...the serigraphs
are very interesting.
They're kind of galactic
or something.
>> Manivong: Very modern looking.
>> Herrera: Very modern looking.
Kind of like a new
universe coming into being.
>> Manivong: Right.
[ Laughter ]
>> Herrera: Maybe that's
what he's talking about.
Maybe it corresponds.
A mist in the trees.
A mist in the trees and
new stars, old songs.
Maybe that's going on.
Beautiful poems, beautiful
serigraphs,
beautiful book, beautiful
collection.
>> Manivong: Thank you.
>> Herrera: Thank you so much.
>> Manivong: Thank you for coming.
>> Herrera: Thank you Mark.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.